ja ist heute tag der rettung
fragezeichen denn ab 12 uhr findet heute
eine außerordentliche lufthansa
hauptversammlung statt
in der mit spannung erwarteten
aktionärsversammlung soll das halbe
milliarde sparpaket beschlossen werden
bereits gestern demonstrierten
zahlreiche mitarbeiter und mitglieder
der unabhängigen flugbegleiter
organisation für den erhalt ihrer jobs
ein kämpferischer auftritt hunderter
lufthanseaten in frankfurt am main
piloten stewardessen techniker und co
demonstrierten gestern vor dem lufthansa
aviation center groß und klein waren
zusammengekommen um gemeinsam für den
erhalt der arbeitsstellen zu
demonstrieren
[Musik]
die aktion ihren morgen schwimmen
euro die aber wird der anleihen der
wunsch hauptaktionär heinz hermann
thiele soll bei der heutigen
hauptversammlung den staatseinstieg mit
20 prozent zustimmen
durch die korona krise ist lufthansa in
finanzielle schwierigkeiten geraten
insolvenz und zehntausende jobverluste
drohen beteiligt sich der staat nicht an
der fluggesellschaft wir einfach
wünschen dass alles gut ausgeht dass es
wertgeschätzt wird deshalb auch dieser
spruch wir haben euch gerettet werden
und da müssen auch mal ungewöhnliche
maßnahmen her eher zum beispiel hat ein
lied geschrieben
[Musik]
auch wenn der text noch nicht ganz sitzt
warum sie auf der straße sind wissen sie
ganz genau
und um dieses thema jetzt weiter zu
beleuchten ist bei uns im studio
nikolaus harbusch bild reporter und der
expertin dieser thematik nicolas geben
uns noch mal kurz auskunft darüber warum
dieses treffen heute um 12 uhr so
brisant ist der tag der entscheidung für
lufthansa bei der außerordentlichen
mitgliederversammlung die auch als video
schalte stattfindet geht es um nicht
mehr als die zukunft dieses dieser welt
großen fluggesellschaft nummer vier im
weltweiten flugmarkt es gibt nur das
fortbestehen der kranich-airline es geht
um 140.000 jobs es geht darum ob
lufthansa das 9 milliarden euro paket
vom staat bekommen kann
wie steht denn da die chance stand lange
auf der kippe
jetzt sieht alles aus als erwarten wir
heute eine einigung es gibt einen mehr
als aktionär einen großen aktionär ein
seemann thiele hans hermann thiele er
besitzt 15 5 prozent aktien und hat
damit ein gehöriges wörtchen
mitzusprechen insbesondere sind heute
wahrscheinlich nur rund 40 prozent
aktionäre bei der hauptversammlung
vertreten
und er hatte sein veto angekündigt jetzt
hat er sich eines anderen besonnen hat
gestern gesagt er wolle heute der
vorlage zustimmen und nun sind scheinen
alle ampeln auf grün und sieht so aus
als könnten die neun milliarden euro
die wichtig sind für den fortbestand der
lufthansa von den neun milliarden euro
rettung sind sechs milliarden staatliche
unterstützung drei milliarden sind
kredite und von diesem gesamtpaket sind
circa 500 millionen
für die rettung der arbeitsplätze habe
ich das richtig verstanden dass so die
aufteilung und kommt man denn damit auch
über die runden
ja also neun milliarden euro ist eine
gigantische summe die dort an
staatshilfe jetzt zusammenkunft in
richtung lufthansa fließt dazu kommen
weitere weitere hilfen für die lufthansa
töchter in österreich die austrian
airline daran beteiligt sich der
österreichische staat es gibt bei helfen
oder zuflüsse für die swissair aus der
schweiz
auch die brussels bekommt geld vom
belgischen staat aber alles in allem
bleibt es bei diesen 9 milliarden euro
und jetzt überlegt man aber wie man auch
geld einsparen kann das ist jetzt schon
klar dass nicht mehr die ganze flotte in
die luft gehen wird sondern dass
wahrscheinlich im bereich von 100
flugzeugen zukünftig am boden bleiben
dann braucht man auch weniger personal
da muss geld eingesperrt werden und da
gab es diese nacht verhandlungen und da
hat sich die kabinen gewerkschaft ufo
mit der lufthansa führung auf ein
sparpaket von 500 millionen euro
geeinigt nikolaus harbusch vielen dank
für deine einschätzung und zur stunde
will die unabhängige flugbegleiter
organisation ufo am lufthansa aviation
center am flughafen frankfurt
demonstrieren für den erhalt ihrer jobs
und dort ist meine kollegin dieser
gödert vor ort lisa wie ist die stimmung
was genau werden die demonstranten heute
noch von sich geben
die mannschaft war für 9 uhr angesetzt
hier sind piloten hier sehen
flugbegleiter hier sind leute aus der
technik und anderen bereichen der
lufthansa auch von der sun express wo
die deutsche sportler eingestellt wird
sind vertreter hier heute wollen die
mitarbeiter einfach noch einmal zeigen
dass sie zusammenstehen auf den boden
wie auch in der luft sie wollen nicht
dass den panisch die flügel gebrochen
werden sie wollen einfach noch einmal
zeigen dass sie zusammenhalten und wie
wichtig es für sie ist dass dieser
airline
erhalten bleibt das heißt wenn jetzt
schon applaus zu hören ist und die
stimmung offensichtlich gut ist dann ist
die nachricht auch schon durchgedrungen
dass die jobs der demonstranten der
mitarbeitern gesichert ist für die
zukunft die stimmung ist auf jeden fall
deutlich besser als gestern es sind
bisher auch ein wenig weniger als es
sind weniger leute hier als gestern aber
das muss man jetzt noch sehen wie sich
das entwickelt das ganze ist ja bis 12
uhr angesetzt
aber auf jeden fall sieht man auch schon
ein lächeln bei den leuten auf den
gesichtern teilweise die wissen auf
jeden fall schon bescheid dass sich
optionen aufgetan haben dennoch ist es
natürlich spannend was dort heute
verkündet wird ab 12 uhr wir werden
natürlich mit dabei sein
du hast gerade angesprochen dass es
weniger leute sind als gestern was ist
so die ungefähre teilnehmerzahl heute
schwer zu schätzen
ich würde jetzt mal sagen dass bisher 3
400 leute hier sind sehr gut aus
frankfurt vielen dank für deine
einschätzung wir schalten sicherlich zu
später stunde um 12 nochmal zu dir danke